thank you very much and I am very
honored to be here you know giving a
lecture at the Stanford University is
involves in a lifetime event so it's I'm
very excited I'm going to talk about the
preferred networks and its values you
know how we are going to make you know
changes in the society and from from the
AI and know deep learning perspective
which are gave me give you some
introduction about me but he said I
spent 26 years at IBM research I spent
almost one year at a channel so I spent
my time in us-based global company as
well as Japan based global company and
also in academia now I am in a startup
company my background is a computer
science and but but in addition to that
I have some management experiences so
from that perspective I'm going to talk
about about you know deep learning and
you know how we form networks is
managing these technologies to make that
biggest impact on to the society the
company preferred networks sometimes we
believed it as a PFN and I don't know
why is there that people networks is
founded four and a half years ago before
that actually our co-founders started
the previous company called the pre for
the infrastructure about eleven years
ago while they were other graduate
student at the University of Tokyo we
have an office in Tokyo and we have a
small offices in Berkeley California the
current number of employees about 180
people most of them out seen 170 are
engineers and researchers
when I joined the company two and a half
years ago there were about 40 people so
we are growing very very quickly we have
a big investors like an entity phonic
Toyota and recently we have investment
from Hakata the big PR company in Japan
Hitachi mr. ho pang meetly is a trading
company and a chill guy pharmaceutical
is a part of a rush so it's a big
pharmaceutical group of companies and
also total electron is semiconductor
equipping the company we have no major
capital investment to us that is because
of our co-founders policy that they need
to keep the freedom of whatever they
want to do our focus is this repeatedly
planning and apply to certain areas in
and I'm going to talk about that but
before that I want to you to understand
the clip Korean differentiation between
AI and deep learning so let me start
with AI so you know there are several
different approaches to intelligence so
there are many different disciplines
like you know neuroscience brain science
approaches to study the brain by
observing the brain activities
psychology studied human mind by
observing the human behaviors in
economics of course that they need to
model in human behaviors and they use
mathematical models such as a no
geometry and optimization and so on in
mechanical engineering there is a
differential equations so they you know
do the control theory based on this you
know mathematical motors and then
computer science is uploading to the
intelligence
by creating the mimicking the human
intelligence so you know there are many
different ways to approach the human
intelligence at the beginning of the AI
history in a computer science you know
first people thought about what
intelligence is and one of the things
that thought they thought is that
integers maybe you know do a complex
mathematics so you know doing a
mathematics is like you know this is an
integral of a mathematical formula by
the way you know this is integral sign
now at that time you know there was no
tech so you know you have to write the
integral sign by combining the ASCII
characters but you know this was a very
successful AI applications in the early
days I can do the mathematical
integration integration integral
computation calculation by myself but it
does bill girl another study was natural
language understanding Cassini people
thought that intelligence means that you
can use language so this is one of the
early attempts to do it in a natural
language understanding and you know the
professor McGrath is here now this
moment at that time he was in MIT Media
Lab and I remember myself that I have
read his PhD thesis and I was very
excited and there this is the area that
I wanted to work on so you know his
system I'll call the pseudo is is to
simulate the robotic environment and it
understand human language and based on
the human language input it does things
like you know if you say pick up a big
word book you may notice that there are
two blocks
red blocks and it understand you are
meaning that that the big one over here
and to move this block you need to
remove the green one first and and so on
so you know this this is a very very
intelligent system and it was very
successful but it was in 1970s
and we don't see much advances after
that some people thought that the intent
is to play games against the human
export so in 1997 IBM deep blue beat the
Kasparov towards the the chess Grand
Champion and as you remember the google
alphago beat the East settle in two
years ago so you did out the successes
of artificial intelligence but if you
look at the technologies in high
technologies by piece by piece then you
may notice that these technologies will
be incorporated into the deep daily
computer science so the first wave of AI
was like a 1950's and 1960's and at that
time the focus of AI research is for
example in a symbolic processing because
at that time computer means to calculate
the you know numerical calculation
people started to think about symbol
processing and for that McCarthy
developed a programming language called
the Lisp
also there's a lot of studies regarding
the search algorithms like a means and
analysis if we are if I want to go to my
home in Tokyo from here then if I
calculate my path going out of this
building in the maker right of make left
and so on then I will never get my home
the mean and analysis says that if we I
want to go to the Tokyo then the first
the longest legs should be determined
first so you know flying from San
Francisco Airport to Tokyo and then
going to the sub-problem which is to go
to the San Francisco Airport from here
so that's called means and analysis and
it was a hot topic in artists artists
area encourages but nowadays you know
you use Google and you know a bird or
whatever to look for the the path and it
is no no longer called
AI so you know Tim striking and garbage
collection or search algorithms or
language passing these were the you know
AI technologies before but it no longer
a I the second wave of AI but focusing
on things like a knowledge
representation or expert systems in
ontology and those kind of things and as
you know these concepts are now part of
for example in across hierarchy of the
object-oriented language or modeling
language or Semantic Web and endings so
I argue that the third wave of AI whose
focus is statistical machine learning or
deep learning now these technologies
will be part of the daily computer
science in the future and people will
not say that this is you know I I so I
means many different things okay for the
researchers of course in there is no
research field called the artificial
intelligence but the focused
technologies are different from time to
time cooperations AI means something
that uses some of the technologies like
a search you know knowledge
representation and so forth so now a I
speakers
uses speech recognition AI
microwave oven uses you know some
heuristics to do
the cooking and the AI air conditioners
detects the human beings in the room and
optimize their operations and then there
is general public for which you know
sometimes i means human-like robots like
hollow nine total zero in in the movie
Terminator Cylon in agaric Galactica and
Astro Boy you know that it's a Japanese
cartoon so you know I means many
different things in based on the context
and especially I'd like to use to
distinguish between generalized AI and
specialized AI there was an interview
article in Wired magazine two years ago
at mr. Obama said that there is a
generalized AI and the specialized AI
and we make distinctions I don't know in
the current administration understand
this distinction or not but you know he
said that generalized AI is a sci-fi so
it's you know we have to make sure that
what we are talking about okay so from
now on I'm not talking about AI but I am
specifically talk about deep learning or
statistical machine learning so what is
deep learning well in a single sentence
you know deep learning is a function so
function means that it takes an input
and it generates output that's simple
okay usually we have a very large
dimensional variable as an input so if
you do the image of a cognition I can
have 100 pixels and 100 pixel which
means you have the vector with the
10,000 elements
in it okay so it's very high-dimensional
data but it's just an input and output
could be very simple if you detect you
know cat or you know airplane in the
picture then you know you have probably
two bits as an outlet we know one is for
airplane and one is for cat if you want
to generate some images as an output
then the image output could be also very
very high-dimensional but that's that's
it it's it's just an a function okay
when you build a function by using the
traditional programming what you do let
me give you an example using this a very
very simple example which is to convert
Celsius to Fahrenheit so the traditional
way of doing the programming got some
programming a function is to start with
the specification requirements so you
know here the input here its output and
then you translate these requirements to
a model so motor by model I mean that
the Delta mathematical relationship
between input and output and you usually
use you use in known knowledge about the
input and output relationships so in
this case you know this is the model
okay and then once you get the model
then you construct the algorithms to
calculate the the model so and we you
use a priori knowledge to do that
modeling so the the fundamental
assumption here is that you know the
model okay and also the algorithm to
compute the model is in constructible so
these are the prerequisite for doing the
convention of programming on the other
hand the statistical modeling approach
is to do like this so you know
converting the Roman Celsius and
Fahrenheit I by
you know two thermometers one in the
sauces and once it's in Fahrenheit and I
read these thermometers from time at a
time and get this kind of data set and
the question is you know what is the
best way to simulate this input and
output relationship and that's what we
do in statistical mast statics color
modeling was statistical machine
learning you know statical mastery
learning is basically the same thing as
a static static remodeling so it's known
for a long time so for these kinds of
things but it's very easy for you to do
this kind of modeling so this is called
regression a linear regression so linear
regression is actually a part of machine
learning okay but then traditional
statistical statists statistical
modeling has one limitation which is
that you have to determine the model
family in advance so let me take this
example so this is a training dataset
and the question that what is the model
that is going to approximate this input
and output so if you select the linear
model as a model family then you get
this okay if you assume that the cubic
function then there you get a better
approximation well if you have a larger
dimensions in the in a polynomial
function then what you get is like this
and this is known to be over fitting in
a statistical modeling and this is the
difficulty of the statistical modeling
you have to define the model model
family which is powerful enough to
represent the training dataset but not
too powerful to be overfitting okay so
that's the
Challenge on the other hand if being
used deep learning I created a very
simple deep neural network and trained
this neural network with the same input
data set okay
and this deep neuron that hurts and two
internal layers and each layer has an
attend nodes so there is a you know each
link has hits a weight parameter so this
model has a hundred forty one parameters
in total and from the common sense of
the traditional statistical modeling
because there is a hundred forty one
freedom and degree of freedom and the
input data our training data has only 50
points so it must over fit but somehow
the deep learning does a good
approximation without too much over 50
and this is the biggest difference from
the traditional statistical modeling
from with the deep learning how deep
learning is powerful is also a very
interesting question and the deep neural
network usually have at you know
millions of parameters which means it
can approximate any high dimensional
function so in a sense it is an acid
Turing complete I mean by by that I mean
that any functions for any functions
there is just some deep neural network
that can approximate a function to a
certain era how the deep learning is
trained is there is some very good video
by young Luca who is the CTO of Facebook
unfortunately this video is not
available
but the idea is like this suppose that
you want to create a deep neural network
which detects whether the input image is
a car or dog okay so there is there are
small are two lamps for the car and for
the other one is that or dog and you
showed a car picture and you want this
box to light the car lamp but of course
that at the beginning the box does not
have any knowledge about the car or dog
so what we do is to short one image no
car image and there's probably you know
the car alarm that's not like so in that
case there's many dials and you adjust
the dials so that the car lamp lights
brighter and brighter then you show that
dog image and make sure that the car
lamprey is off and the dog lamp is you
know coming brighter and brighter and so
on so you repeat this kind of a
procedure for many many times and after
that you this box understand that which
is car and which is dog okay and the
difference from this you know simple
model is that the number of diodes like
millions or tens of millions typically
okay and also you have to show you know
the same image again and again again for
Big E times so you use lots of
computation lots of trial and error and
but after that you get not trained in
the model and with this model what can
we do now this is you know one example
that we are working on which is for the
autonomous driving this is an input
image and this is output and for each
pixel in the input image we determine
that this picture belongs to the
drivable
office or sidewalk or other cuts in
trees and so on you know that 25
different classes in this example but
you can think of you know the car in the
dog box for each pixel in this case
you'd area to 25 different lamps in the
box and there are so many boxes in you
know in this example so it's just you
know scaling of the simple model to this
you know large system but of course in a
delicate catch which is you know to do
this you have to create a training
dataset so for this is an input and this
is the grand truth created by human
being okay so you know we prepare the
the ground truth training data for
thousand or tens of thousands of images
okay and using with this as on a
training the dataset we train the neural
network and finally we get this okay in
a sense you know this problem you know
taking this picture and generates that
this is this picture belongs to the
drivable surface or you know sidewalks
this is a function okay but you cannot
give the model you cannot mathematically
describe that this is you know if this
mathematical property holds in this
input image then that this picture is a
drivable socks you know you cannot do
that so in this case the model is
unknown but you can provide at the
examples and for that kind of
applications deep learning can solve
this problem the second example or
similar example which is this is video
that when we participated in
picking the challenge the task is to
specify the object from from the shelf
okay you know Amazon warehouse is very
highly automated but picking the object
from the shelf is done by a human being
because this is known to be very very
difficult the difficult part is to
understand where that specify the object
is and we take the pictures is tell me
we put the randomly all many you know
items in in a shelf and took a pictures
and annotated that these pictures by
hand with thousands of these you know
training dataset we train a new deep
neural network and after that you know
we very accurately identify where the
object is so actually you know also we
are we won the second place in this
competition again you know the in this
case in a model is unknown so you know
what is the mathematical relationship
between this picture and you know this
picture belongs to a water bottle the
third example that I can give you is the
voice control
okay can you make a volume higher
sure I'll work on them okay let me go
back to motor duckie
so in this case in a city you do that
your human bias to control the robot so
top and the bottom is a chelina operated
perspective so this side is the top and
this side is the bottom so in this case
she said tissue box machine is going to
use a different expression to it sure
I'll work on that
so how did we train this model well you
know this is a top of view of the
situation
and we showed this kind of image to
human beings and asked what would you
say if you want to move you know this
object over there and we crowd sourced
this you know data collection and we
collected the thousand of tens of
thousands of example sentences and use
between sentences to train the neural
network so there's no kind no you know
understanding of natural language
sentences it's just you know giving the
examples and again we cannot specify the
mathematical relationship between the
input centers and the operations okay so
here the model is unknown but we can
generate examples so that's where a deep
learning can help to create a solution
the second way to use deep learning is
where even though the motor is done but
still the algorithm is not known okay
this is an example of you know coloring
the line drawings so left hand side is
the input the line drawing and our deep
neural network automatically make it
color the version of the image
and sometimes you can put the hints so
you know I wanted this part in red and
so the interesting thing is how did we
train this model well we collected a lot
of colored images from the internet okay
and we apply the edge detection
algorithms which generates line drawings
from the colored image you know it is
known algorithm and
so you know from here to there there is
a known algorithm so we apply the edge
detection and generates a lot of a pairs
over line drawings and colored image and
using this adds on a data set train you
dead set we train our deep neural
network so in this case you know that in
a relationship between the color the
image and line rulings it's you know if
you apply edge detection then you know
that but you don't know the reverse
function okay and so deep learning can
use for that kind of applications
another example that I can give you is
to control machines so this is an
example that we show that computer
electronic consumer electronics show two
years ago
this is autonomous driving demonstration
this is not a rare cards in this is
motor cars you know inside it's a Lego
mind storm but silver cars are control
fully autonomously by deep learning red
car is operated by our vice president
he's you know controlling manual and
he's not good at you know driving the
car you know he's hitting and also you
know they were naturally teams against
the other carts but you may notice that
the similar course not very good
avoiding opportunity in hitting other
cars so the question is how did we train
this model okay you know in this case
you can specify the mathematical
constraints you know the the car moves
you should not hit each other so it's
it's a very simple mathematical
statement but how you control the cause
is not easy okay so let me show you the
video so the way it is a trend is to use
the so called the reinforcement learning
that we use a simulator if you look at
the car in a circle this has this car
has a simulated virtual sense of beams
to a thirty two different angles and get
the the sensor input so these are the
sensor input and this is output which is
to accelerate or move right move left or
to back up and so there are only a five
bit of output and input is 256 sensor
input plus some other current situation
of the car and total twenty seventy 273
input dimension the car will get a
reward if it makes a forward movement
and it gets a penalty if he hits other
cars or hit the the world and we use
deep learning to calculate the from the
earth input to output and based on the
you know you're the penalty teacher
signal it adjust the the many knobs and
so on and try to learn how to drive so
at first it just do a random movement
but then by doing the rudder movement
sometimes you know it go forward and get
the reward and in the parameters are
adjusted and from the next time it now
knows
moving in a Ford is a good thing to do
and finally it has enough smooth
movement and probably you notice that
the the car is moving outside of the car
we didn't did not tell the cause to do
that but by you know doing a lot of
trial and error they noticed that moving
the outside of the car gives a higher of
velocity and which gives a higher reward
and that's why you know they learn to do
that ok we did it a similar thing for
the wrong and in this case the task is
to capture the broader flag but you you
cannot move across the hazard which will
be painted in the by the red part you
know Bert is pre-warning the signal for
the red path and we apply the same
technology same reinforcement learning
so give it a reward when it gets the
flag and give the penalty when it moves
on to the heart now the difference
between this and the previous one is
that of course you know we used a
simulator but in this case you know the
wrong case is similar that that's not a
fix that we are behavior of the drone
because you know the wrong is in had a
lot of influences from like you know the
walls or some you know air movement to
it in the room and so on so what we did
is to create the two neural networks one
needs to control the drone and the other
one is to predicts the movement of the
drone by observing
you know this drone movement so with
that we finally get an a good control of
the drone okay so these are the examples
of deep learning but there is a
challenge for a deep bloody which is the
computational load as I said you know
there's a lot of parameters and we have
to do a lot of iterations about the
training so this is a rough estimation
by our VP and this is the assumption
that the one to finish a training using
one gigabyte of training data set within
a one day required someone Teleflora
and with this assumption for example for
the image recognition probably we may
need a temperature probe so 10x of flops
the life science has a lot of data and
we have to have a larger computational
power a speech recognition autonomous
driving
you know these real-time sensor
applications generates a lot of data and
we have to have a lot of computation and
this is a challenge actually that's
challenging for the deep learning and
that's where we developed a technology
called the China which is scalable deep
learning framework by framework I mean
it's a kind of programming language with
that you can create a deep learning
application easily well the China was
originally developed in with the
flexibility as an objectivity because in
a deep learning area there are you know
it's moving very very quickly there are
many papers published every week and we
have to try these ideas to to understand
this you know technology is good for
application or not so that's why you
know we had to develop a chair now with
the flexibility in our mind but as I
said also the computational time is it
very very important so you know we
shifted our focus to the scalability or
framework China and with this China
combined with our a house of
supercomputer we achieved the world
record of the deep learning training you
know immediate training is one of the
standard benchmark for the d-plan
training performance and this is last
December so this is in a heavy
completion so other companies cutting up
but at that time we were the number one
so we successfully completed that image
net training in just 15 minutes in the
previously it was a 1 hour or 30 minutes
we spent a lot of money on purchasing
this supercomputer infrastructure which
has a thousand 224 Pascal GPUs in the
list price of a Pascal GPU is a ten
thousand US dollar apiece so you know
you can do the math how you know
expensively this by the way you know
this program computer what's wrong crowd
the 91st in the worldwide supercomputer
ranking in the companies like us you
know small company has this kind of
computing infrastructure is you know
extraordinary I believe but that is see
the one of the strengths that we have
how we are differentiate ourselves from
others similar things is done just a
month ago which is about Google AI open
terrain open image challenge and we were
in the second place
but the difference with the top one is a
very very small you know we are one of
the best and we used a new supercomputer
which has 500 voltage GPUs and we use
the chain our multi node which is which
gives scalability of the computation so
you know we add more GPUs in a we get no
higher speed so these are about the deep
learning so do deep learning can do many
things but you need a lot of computation
in addition to that there are
fundamental limitations of deep learning
and I want you to understand this
because you know deep learning is it's a
it's not a silver bullet it's it's a
just you know mathematical formula well
that the first limitation is it's is
that we trained a deep neural network
using that data observed in the past and
do the predictions in the future okay so
fundamental assumption here is that the
deep learning assumes that the future is
the same as the past okay at least in a
in a statistical distribution point of
view so that the first limitation the
second one is even though we can assume
that the future and the past are the
same in terms of the statistical
distribution still the training data set
is finite which means there are many
points which are not covered in training
data set if that point is somewhat you
know close to the
and points in the training they've set
then you can make a very good prediction
so it is called interpolation but if the
new input points not anywhere near to
the training dead set then a deep
learning or statistical machine learning
is powerless so sometimes you know
customer comes to us and please create a
deep neural network to deal with very
rare cases or emergency cases but it is
not possible because then we don't have
the training dataset ok so that the
second limitation and the third one is
that this is fundamental fundamentally
statistically so which means we always
assume that there is some original
distribution probability distribution
and probably it is not known but we
assumed that you randomly sample from
this original distribution and create a
training dataset once you get the
training with that setting you can train
your new owner block but the problem is
that in the decision of first phase
which is the assumption that you know
you are doing the random sampling from
the original distribution iid means that
the independent and identical
distribution okay so that means there is
always bias in a sampling well support
that you throw a dice hundred times if
there are chance that's all hundred
times are one or six okay well you know
it's very very unlikely that all that
you know other times are long but you
cannot guarantees that it will not
happen so that means you know the
training dataset has always some bias
and there is no way that you make a 100%
guarantee about the accuracy of the
training at the deep neural network so
this is I think are the most important
limitation of a deep learning or more
generally statistical machine learning
okay so let me recap what is deep run so
deep learning it's just a new way of
programming a new way of programming a
function but no prior knowledge on model
or algorithm isn't necessary preparing
the data set is the key to do the this
kind of a programming and creative was
thinking about how you provide the
teacher signal no teacher signal could
be provided by the human annotators
but could be supplied by you know
reinforcement learning music
assimilators or could be done by some
other ways so creative thinking gives a
very very innovative applications it
requires a lot of computation and also
this is a fundamentally statistics which
means you know there should be you know
that training data set is must be the
iid and it gives the upper key situation
only so there is no guarantee over 100
percent accuracy so that's the deep
running okay so let me talk about the
third topic which is about our company
so we are specialized in a deep learning
and if you look at the deep learning
loves landscape you know many players in
this corner
which is to deal with the cyberspace
data like a text or image on the
internet and things are the consumers
the provider services but we are more
interested in physical world because it
generates a lot of data and also you
know we are facing mainly b2b companies
like a Toyota and the Phonak so that's
our business but then you know there is
a big challenge for us which is you know
how to do a good business in you know
deep running because most of the deep
learning technologies are open sourced
including our China so it can we cannot
make money directly out of China well of
course we can think of doing a
consulting for a particulars customer or
doing a system integration for the
particular customers but that kind of
business were it easy money but that
kind of business does not scale because
we have to the the growth is
proportional to the number of employees
that we have so we have you know higher
growth than just on a linear also if you
put our researchers engineers in a
customer engagement they are tied up
with the customer engagement this many
of the customer engagements is actually
can be done by more common technologies
and they're not cutting-edge
technologies that we have so time spent
on the customer engagement prevent us to
do the more cutting in the research and
engineering so that's the business
challenges that we have what we are
doing is well is first our assumption is
that the technology up in a two-edged
technologies speak themselves
so we don't have any marketing or sales
dedicated personnel you know 90 percent
of our workforce our engineers and
researchers and that also yet that the
cabinet technologies is the best way to
attract the talent from the worldwide
sometimes even people do not know our
company preferred networks but many of
the researchers in deep learning know
China so having the China as an open
source technology it's a very very
strategic for us to attract the people
from the worldwide actually you know
about a 50% of the new applicants to PFN
is from outside of Japan the second is
that we heavily invest on people and on
computational resources and that's is to
stay in a cutting edge and then we have
the current businesses which is to work
with big companies like new Toyota and
of Iraq to the joint research and
development and it generates a healthy
profit for us and you know we keep that
kind of activities but also you know we
work with the new investors to create a
new businesses and we are continuously
working on that but that gives you gives
us you know the breathing space or
freedom of operation and we are looking
at the new opportunities and we don't
know what the new opportunities are at
this moment but we are ready to capture
these new opportunities when it arises
so the most important thing for us is
that we have the technology and we have
the resources when the you know the
right moment comes that's
a la strategy and that's coming to the
our barriers which means you know to do
this what should we do it okay we had a
week longer discussion by everybody in
our company we call this PF n valued
week and everybody participated in the
discussion about new who are we what we
should do how do we differentiate from
others and and so on
and we came up with four value
statements the first one is that we are
motivated motivation driven which means
if you are not want to meet it to do
something then the unit performance is
you know about this level but if you are
strongly motivated to do this then your
performance will be double or triple so
that's the motivation driven and with
that we have a very very flat
organization hey we have the two
founders at the top but everybody has
opposed to them and you know there's a
many project some people browse to the
multiple projects people are moving from
one project to another based on their
old own motivation and how to manage
these people we heavily use the IT like
a track for example and you know with
that our founders can monitor what's
going on in the company and give it up
can give the writer directions whenever
it is necessary so that's the the first
value the second value statement is
learn or die so you know this area is
moving this so quickly that we have to
be learning
every day so our co-founder in the day
Daisuke Kihara had a tweets about the
papers in he read and this is actually a
very good source of the new information
about deep learning so you know we have
to learn in continuously to do so the
third statement is in a proud but humble
which means you know we are the best one
of the best in the deep learning in
industry okay so we know that we are one
of the best but at the same time we know
that there are things that we don't know
so known unknown it's a very very
important for us so that means you know
we you have to be humble and we have to
listen to others no other export in
other areas and so on so that's the
third one and the fourth one is what we
do we do whatever you know and other
people cannot do and that's the reason
why you know we can differentiate
ourselves so that's why no we do not do
get into the you know system integration
or consulting services you know these
are the things that others can do you
know we are focusing on whatever you
know only we can do so that's the
statement and that's in how we are
prepared to capture the best moment in
the in the business so probably you know
you you think that you know it's a very
different from the business mode you
know business model of the other
startups probably we won't be one over
the kind
other other company so you know keep
watching us thank you
[Applause]